the expectation with Hillary becoming
president everybody's donating money to
her foundation which is a laundering I
guess and then the idea is if she
becomes president then those favors get
paid back they purchased something but
she lost and this what I really really
love I just want to shout out the 2016
was you know the that election oh boy I
remember that night oh so well all the
Trump all the all the Trump supporter
well I'm sorry I was at the Sputnik
office with Cassandra Fairbanks and um
Cassandra McDonald sorry and uh she was
the only Trump supporter there everyone
else was upset people were crying and
she was laughing crying and it was funny
but what was really funny about it was
that the establishment machine of money
churn and and revolving doors was just
shattered in an instant and the Panic
was absolutely hilarious for the DC
Elites who owed millions of dollars to
foreign donors and lobbyists that they
weren't going to be able to to uh pay
back now you have Matt Gates doing the
same thing to Kevin McCarthy and all of
that money put into him becoming speaker
was just ripped away from him